Game of Thrones has always been a pretty
sprawling TV show and plenty of material
has ended up on the cutting room floor
but though these scenes were deleted
they're still fascinating to explore
especially since these moments could
have subtly changed the course of the
story or at least our perception of
events let's explore some of the more
substantial moments that never made at
the final cut the execution of
Littlefinger was one of the most
shocking moments in the season 7 finale
but how did Sansa and Arya Stark have
come to learn about his whole lifetime
of crimes in an interview with Variety
actor Isaac Hempstead write who portrays
bran stark revealed that he shot a
deleted sequence of sophie Turner who
portrays Sansa in the scene
Sansa reportedly consulted with bran at
just ahead of Littlefinger's trial as
you may recall a Santa was convinced her
sister Arya was out to assassinate her
in order to become the Lady of
Winterfell Arya suspected the same of
Sansa and it was all thanks to that
master manipulator Littlefinger viewers
were sweating buckets watching the
season 7 finale since it looks like one
of the stark sisters might kill the
other
but then Sansa and Arya flipped the
script sentencing Littlefinger to death
revealing their few to be an elaborate
ruse thank you for all your many lessons
Lord Baelish
I will never forget them it was a big
twist but it seemed to leave a bit of a
plot hole behind - how will our children
suddenly so certain of Littlefinger's
history of manipulation and betrayal
according to Hempstead right a deleted
scene from the episode would have
cleared up any ambiguity it revealed
exactly how the stark sisters learned of
Littlefinger schemes and it would have
led audience to see how Sansa and Arya
arrived at the decision to execute him
in the deleted scene brand uses his
newfound abilities as a three-eyed Raven
to peer into Littlefinger's past another
thing every underhanded thing he'd ever
done in his quest for power M stead
write told variety the story was that it
suddenly occurred to Sansa that she had
a huge CCTV Department at a discretion
and it might be a good idea to check
with bran first before she cuts her own
sister though audiences can kind of
still fill in the blanks about the scene
this inclusion would have fitted the
plot together with a little more clarity
it also would have shed more light on
brands immense powers giving us a much
stronger an impression of how
extraordinary his gifts really are
brand's ability to access the history of
man and the secrets of Westeros is an
astonishing skill and the potentially
powerful weapon as was made clear in
season 8 - brand's knowledge that jon is
the rightful heir to the Seven Kingdoms
sparked an unfortunate chain of events
one that's played an important part in
Daenerys Targaryen star sent into
madness Sansa has undergone a remarkable
transformation since we first met a
dreamy young girl looking forward to
marriage and one person who's had a
major hand in her development as Sandor
Clegane
otherwise known as the Hound throughout
much of Game of Thrones he seemed
ultimately drawn to and repulsed by sons
as innocents frequently calling her
little bird with a mixture of sweetness
and condescension no little bird I won't
hurt you of course the Hound uses that
nickname again in the fourth episode of
season 8 when the dynamics between the
two our remarkably different it's a
scene that highlights just how much
Sansa has grown throughout the course of
Game of Thrones
you've changed little bird yet one
deleted scene all the way back in season
two depicts a Sansa who's already
prepared to stand up to the hound I
don't know any songs not anymore instead
of a quivering wave we see a young woman
who's perfectly willing to stand her
ground and perhaps that was the problem
a scene of her standing up for herself
even a little bit could have been seen
as too much too soon as far as senseless
development is concerned Sansa and the
Hound season a reunion certainly
wouldn't have been half as bittersweet
if she'd already demonstrated the
potential for such strength away back in
season two tormund has always been right
at the center of the tension between the
Nights Watch and the wildlings he's
helpful to the Nights Watch but he's not
sentimental about their history he's
committed to being part of the free folk
but he's also Jon Snow's friend when Jon
was the commander of the Nights Watch he
welcomed torment and other wildlings
across the wall that brought attention
to its boiling point resulting in the
slaying of Jon Snow in a deleted scene
from season 5 that would have taken
place before Jon's death and
resurrection ser Alliser Thorne one of
snows eventual killers verbally spars
with tormund
he let Stormin know just how much he
distrusts him and how little he likes
housing him tormund gruffly replies he
must no longer be in charge Stan it's a
moment of intense foreshadowing but had
the scene being included in the show it
might have made torment seem partially
responsible for Jon Snow's murder
however involuntarily though he didn't
we ordered dagger his aggressive
needling of Alistar might have been
perceived as a straw that broke the
camel's back
audiences might have blamed torment for
sir Alice's subsequent actions though
the scene is appropriate for that era of
the show it may well have cast a pall
over an alliance that has since helped
shape the future of Westeros Game of
Thrones Minds conflict from absolutely
every angle life against death that
woman against man religion against
cynicism another major clash the ongoing
animosity between the nobility and
common folk of Westeros the prostitute
Shae had a pretty long run on Game of
Thrones but her luck eventually ran out
first it was her damaging testimony
against Tyrion Lannister who then
tragically killed her when he
encountered her in his father's bed it
was tragic and it was extreme
Berthe deleted scene between Shae and
Bronn reveals a far more tender side to
the conflict and it might change how you
view Shay's actions
the scene prawn commiserate ceviche as a
fellow commoner these people even the
good ones their uses as they please and
when we're no longer any use they spit
us out it's the kindest we've ever seen
bran and the moments emphasizes the
difficult position that Shay was in we
have to adapt to circumstances is one
saying learn some new tricks with this
scene in mind what happens between Shay
and Tyrion becomes even more complicated
yes she does something awful but this
seemed as to ask what choice did she
have grand maester pycelle was always a
conniving man even when acting like a
doddering old fool he delighted in
playing passive-aggressive games and
he'd never miss an opportunity to
dismiss and disrespect Tyrion but his
detestable nature often went completely
unnoticed by other characters on Game of
Thrones and even when two noticed by
many people watching the show but the
deleted scene between pycelle and Tywin
Lannister would have changed that
dynamic enormous Lee pycelle interrupts
Tywin while he's fishing and as usual
he's playing the fool in order to seem
non-threatening and inept unimpressed by
the charade Tywin cuts off Parcells
babbling am I the only one to see
through this performance this certainly
changes the dynamic between pycelle and
Tywin it also suggests that most of the
other people in King's Landing are
comparable heed aft the scene doesn't
just make Tywin seem more formidable it
also changes how we see pycelle now he
seems like a dangerous and devious man
instead of a mild annoyance in the
second season of Game of Thrones
Daenerys learns an important lesson in
trust after she's ferociously betrayed
by a handmaiden Turia
said you'd never leave Qarth alive
Duryea meets a holy unfortunate end with
an heiress sealing her inside a vault to
die which is an arguably kind of a harsh
way to take somebody else as it turns
out we didn't even see the worst of the
Ria's actions in a deleted scene from
season two she gleefully strangles
tenaris his handmaid an eerie to death
of course that scene effectively turns
Duryea into a far more insidious
character and it makes her betrayal seem
so much worse than what we ever saw on
screen the White Walkers were always a
major threat in Game of Thrones but it
was also a major challenge to get the
people of Westeros to believe the threat
was real Jon Snow spent an enormous
chunk of screen time arguing about the
walkers though few people were as
willing to take his warnings or brands
visions to heart a crippled boy claims
to have seen dead men on a much beyond
the wall thanks for the magical help of
a raven with three eyes it is a bit much
but in a deleted season2 scene that we
never got to see it's revealed that
Tywin Lannister took the White Walkers
quite seriously from early on after
hearing stories of corpses with blue
eyes and their bone white masters Tywin
discusses sending an MV to mance rayder
and then the king-beyond-the-wall
this plot developments would have
seriously changed our perception of
Tywin and it would have considerably
raised the stakes for the Lannisters as
a whole at the scene aired we would have
seen the first major house start
preparing for battle with the White
Walkers far ahead of time or pretty much
everyone else was too busy being
skeptical
Renly's death was a lynchpin of several
plot threads Melisandre's dark and
complex magic the Tyrells and satiable
thirst for power and the war of the five
kings Renly had the charm and charisma
that Stannis lacked he had the backing
of a large and fruitful house and
brilliant women like Margaery at his
side at this point it's also easy to
forget what a genuine threat he was but
above and beyond that Renly was lorises
lover and the deleted scene from season
two illustrates their love of the
tenderness that's rather unusual for the
world of Game of Thrones in the scene
Loras laments his inability to stop
Renly's murder confiding in his sister
Margaery that he feels somewhat
responsible for his lovers death
Margaery urges Loras to turn his
attention to the family we have to think
of our house now a whole country's at
war this scene makes the Tyrells
emotional stakes all the more clear it's
easy to see Margaery as conniving above
all else
but this unusually touching moment
illustrates that she still very much
loves her brother Olenna Tyrell was one
of the most fearsome characters in Game
of Thrones a brilliant strategist a
cynical plotter and the devoted
grandmother she was a woman who'd do
anything to protect her family and their
interests case in point
her murder of Joffrey Baratheon at his
wedding in a deleted scene from season
six she discusses the Lannisters with
her son
mace Tyrell after Mays has made Circe's
master of coin he's evidently unable to
see how it's being manipulated but al
Ennis sees exactly what's going on and
she's determined to keep Loras and
Margaery as safe as possible
a master sent you to brought us to get
you out of her way and she sent the
bloody Kingsguard to make certain you
stayed that the scene brings to light
exactly how close sir sees plan came to
ending in failure and how enormous Lee
the Tyrells would go on to loose in
season seven and thus how powerful
Cersei truly is but a last season of the
series though forces were arrayed on
both the Tyrell and Lannister sides it
all came down to a game of wits between
the queen of Westeros and the Queen of
thorns the direwolves have always been
more than pets their fates are
foreshadowed and influenced the face of
the stark children from the very
beginning from ladies death and Sansa
subsequent suffering to gray winds
mutilation and rubs murder at the red
wedding in a deleted scene from season 7
Jon gives ghost an important task before
he sets off to meet Daenerys keeps Sansa
safe dose is essentially the only stark
a dire wolf left yes there's still night
Miriah but that's the story for another
day the fact that John entrusted this
job to ghost is a sign of just how
deeply he cares for Sansa it also
emphasizes how important Sansa Arya John
and bran are to each other their strong
Alliance has survived that of the
Lannisters the Tyrells and the Targaryen
ghost is a part of John or at least he
used to be before the king in the north
up and ditched him in season eight you
really do know nothing Jon Snow check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos about Game
of Thrones are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and at the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]